تحركات روسيه غير متوقعه للتسعيد وضع
بمدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه ويليامبرز التحرك مسافرا الى
كييف سرا للتقدم مع الرئيس جنسكي وكبار
قادته الاسبوع الماضي وعرض عليهم معلومات
وتوقعات الاستخبارات للمخططات الروسيه
العسكريه المحتمله في الاسابيع المقبله
وفقا لمسؤول امريكي
وعزز دعمنا المستمر لاوكرانيا في دفاعا ضد
العدوان الروسي
المعلومات التي قدمها برنس خلال زيارته
لاوكرانيا ليست معروفه لكنها تشبه
المعلومات التي قدمتها الاستخبارات
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا سابقا والذي ساهمت
بفشل روسيا في الاستيلاء على مطار انطنوفو
برنس
جديده من الجانب الروسي في هذه الحاله لا
اعتقد اننا نراها
اهميه زياره البرونز لاوكرانيا تكمل بان
الرجل كان سفيرا لامريكا في موسكو وشغل
منصبا في الخارجيه ويعد من اهم خبراء
الحكومه الامريكيه في الشان الروسي وفهم
عقليه موسكو ما جعله قادرا على توقع
الخطوط روسيا وعسكريا ومنصبه
الاستخباراتيه يجعل معلوماته بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا بمثابه الكنز وعمر العربيه